[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICK KREEGER: Hey, everybody.
My name's Nick, and this
is my colleague, Yannick.
We're going to talk today
about JavaScript and ML.
TensorFlow.js is a library
we launched last year.
It's a library for training
and deploying ML models
in the browser and on Node.js.
We want to showcase what you
can do today with the platform
and where we're going.
One of the great parts
about the library
is there's really no
drivers to install.
If you run it in the browser,
you can get out-of-the-box GPU
acceleration.
The browser itself tends to
be very interactive by nature,
which builds really
great applications
and demos for using ML.
And privacy is a very
important part to the library.
You can run inference
and training locally
on the client, which works
around all sorts of privacy
issues you might have with
doing server-side inference
or training.
And what can you do
today with the library?
Well, we have a collection
of pre-trained, off-the-shelf
models that you can use
without any knowledge of ML.
We also have the ability to
take existing Python models
and convert them and run
them in TensorFlow.js.
We also have a full stack
for training, inference,
and low-level linear algebra.
And that runs in the
browser and Node.js.
And we also have a
bunch of platforms
that JavaScript can run on
outside of just the browser.
The first thing I
want to showcase
is some of our new,
off-the-shelf models
we've launched.
The first one is a bunch of
pre-trained-- or off-the-shelf
models are bunch of
pre-trained models.
They are image, audio, and
text classification models.
And the APIs are
all user-friendly.
You don't have to worry
about converting images.
The tensors are resizing.
They're very high-level,
easy-to-use APIs.
These are available on NPM for
local application development.
Or we also have pre-compiled
hosted scripts as well.
We'll also be working on this
a lot in the upcoming year.
We'll have more and more
models as we go forward.
The first model is BodyPix.
We were actually showcasing
this at our booth.
And I want to show you how
easy it is to use this model.
So the first thing we need
do is include the library
and our BodyPix model.
This can be done with
our pre-compiled scripts.
So it's two simple imports.
And the next step is to--
we'll just create
a image in the DOM.
So this is a body
image detection thing.
So I have a picture of my
toddler trying to do yoga.
It's kind of a
funny picture that
isn't so much a human just like
this and finding arms and legs.
So this is Frank.
He's trying to do
something on the couch.
But I want to actually
load the model
and find body parts on Frank.
So the first thing to do is
to load the BodyPix model--
just a simple, one-line call.
And the next step is to call
one of the methods we expose,
which is
estimatePersonSegmentation.
And I can pass in a DOM element.
This returns a JavaScript
object with the width and height
of the object or the image and
a value for every pixel that
was in the image, if
it's an arm, or a leg,
or a head, et cetera.
There's also a bunch of really
easy-to-use methods for doing
filtering on the image.
So I can take the
results of that
and render it
directly on the DOM.
So it shows head,
body, arm, and so on.
Another model we just launched
just a couple of weeks
ago is the Toxicity model.
It's a out-of-the-box
text classification model.
Again, to use this model, we'll
use the pre-hosted scripts--
two lines of code.
And then I'll load
the Toxicity model
and ask the model
to classify just
some really lovely text,
pretty PG-- you suck.
And I'll get a result back
again as a JavaScript object
that has the seven
labels that we identify
different types of toxic type
text, and the probabilities,
and if it matches.
We also have the ability to
take pre-trained Python models
and run them
directly in browsers.
So if you have a pre-trained
model today that's already
been trained in Python world,
we have a command line tool
that makes it very easy to
serialize the model as a JSON
object, and the weights,
and distribute them
in a web format.
We support Saved Model,
TFHub, and Keras models.
The converter itself
right now supports
over 170 and counting ops.
And we will be TensorFlow
2.0 compatible.
I want to walk through how
simple it is to use this.
I have a Python model.
I run it through the
command line tool,
and then I can easily just
a load that in my JavaScript
application.
Very simple.
And with that, I want to
hand it off to Yannick
to walk through
our training APIs.
YANNICK ASSOGBA: Thanks, Nick.
So in addition to working
with pre-trained models,
TensorFlow.js also allows you
to author and train models
directly in JavaScript, both
in the browser and in Node.
The primary tool for
this is the Layers API,
which is a Keras-compatible
API for authoring models.
There's also a lower
level op-driven API,
if you need fine control
over model architecture
or execution.
And we're going to
take a quick look
at what TFJS code for
training looks like.
And the main
takeaway is that it's
pretty similar to
using Keras and Python,
but follows JavaScript
conventions.
So the first step is
to import the library.
And when working in Node,js,
you can also use the Node.js
bindings, which execute the
TensorFlow operations using
native compiled C++ code.
If you're on a system
that supports CUDA,
you can import
tfjs-node-gpu to get
CUDA-accelerated
performance when
doing training or inference.
And this is what creating
a convolutional model
for a classification task
looks like in JavaScript.
As you can see, it's very
similar to Keras code
and Python.
We start by
instantiating a model.
We add our convolutional
layers, and we finish our model
definition by adding a flatten
operation and a dense layer
with a number of output classes.
Similar to Python, we
use model.compile to get
it ready for training.
And here, we specify our loss
function and our optimizer.
And model.fit is the function
that drives the train loop.
In JavaScript, it's
an async function.
So here, we want to
wait for the result,
or wait for it to be done.
Once the model is done
training, we can save the model.
And here, we're saving it to
the browser's local storage.
We support saving to a
number of different targets,
both on the client
and on the server.
And finally, just
like you're used to,
you can use model.predict to
get a result from the model.
So over the past year,
we've also heard feedback
from the community on ways
we can improve the experience
of training with TensorFlow.js.
And two particular
requested areas
are that of data management
and data visualization.
So we'd like to show you
some of the progress we've
made in those areas.
So first up is tf.data.
And it's an API
for managing data
pipelines to drive training.
It's a JS analog
to Python's tf.data
and provides a whole
set of utility functions
for data set transformation.
And finally, it
works with streams.
And the lazy
evaluation allows you
to work with data that
doesn't fit in memory,
which can be quite important.
So let's take a look
at a simple example.
So here, we load up a CSV
file, using tf.data.csv loader.
And we specify that we want to
predict the price column, using
the isLabel attribute.
So this is going to
set it as a label
in future transformations.
So for example, in this
map transformation,
the price data has
been separated out
into that y's object.
And the rest of the features
are in the x's object.
Once we've flattened
our data, we
can now apply typical ML
transformation operations,
including things like shuffling,
which is an ML best practice,
and batching, which will do
the work of creating properly
sized mini-batches
for training and know
what to pull into memory when,
when the train loop is running.
And the other kinds
of transformations
you may want to do here include
things like normalization.
And finally, we run the
train loop on this data set.
So model.fitDataset is
an analog to model.fit
that supports
consuming TF data sets
and knows how to pull the right
stuff into memory as needed.
And that's tf.data.
So the other area
we've been responding
to community feedback is
that of visualization.
And the first thing I
want to talk about here
is tfjs-vis, which is a library
for in-browser visualization
of model behavior.
So with it, you can
view training behavior,
model internals, as well
as evaluation metrics.
And we're going to take
a look at the first two.
So first, we import the library.
And here, you should note
that we do provide tfjs-vis
as a separate package.
And to visualize
training behavior,
we can use this
show.fitCallbacks function.
And we're going to
specify a named drawing
area to render the charts to,
as well as our metrics that we
want to see.
So in one line,
show.fitCallbacks
will plot our selected
metrics, in this case our loss
and our accuracy or
metrics on batch end
and at the end of each epoch.
So this lets us view how
the model is converging live
in the browser.
That's [? adjust ?]
[? hyper parameters ?]
as usual.
You can also look at
the model internals
with functions like
show.modelSummary
and show.layer.
And similarly we pass
these named drawing areas.
And here, we see the
architecture of the model,
including things like output
shapes of the various layers
and the number of
trainable parameters.
And in this example, we
also see the distribution
of values in the first
convolutional layer
of this network, including
important statistics, like nans
and 0 counts, which are
useful for debugging models.
And finally, we also want to
announce TensorBoard support
in Node.js.
Now you can monitor
training performance right
in TensorBoard when using
the TensorFlow.js layers
API in Node.
You can see what
that looks like.
So a single line will generate
the necessary callbacks
to write the model metrics
to a TensorBoard log file,
using this
tf.node.tensorBoard command.
Then you can open
it in TensorBoard
and look at how you're
training is going,
just like you may be used to.
And with that, I'm going
to hand it back to Nick
to talk about some of the
platforms we execute on.
NICK KREEGER: JavaScript's
an interesting language
because it actually runs in a
lot more places than you think.
There's the traditional
browser front
for running JavaScript
in the browser.
We all know about that.
Node.js is a big
server-side solution.
Very popular.
But there's also a growing trend
with JavaScript in more places.
One of them is
desktop applications.
Electron is a very,
very popular platform
for developing applications.
Those of you who have
used the Spotify desktop
application or Visual
Studio Code, those
are good examples of Electron.
And JavaScript is also
moving into the mobile space.
I want to highlight
a couple of examples
that we've seen in the
industry on all four platforms.
First is the browser.
Our friends at
Google Creative Labs
have built a series
of experiments
to explore how
creative tools can be
more accessible for everyone.
There's going to be
a great lightning
talk on this tomorrow,
and I encourage you to go.
And they'll talk about
everything they've
built with this project.
Uber has built a
in-browser tool for
model-agnostic visualization
of ML performance.
They use TensorFlow.js for
acceleration of their linear
algebra--
k-means clustering, KL-divergent
computations, and so on.
They are also giving
a great lighting talk
about how they use
TensorFlow.js solve this problem
for their platform.
And again, this
is all in-browser.
Another really cool
industry example is Airbnb.
Airbnb built a identity
document detection model
that they use as a full
TensorFlow ecosystem solution.
So on your Airbnb
profile, if you
were to upload a
government-issued ID,
it is a very big trust
and safety issue.
So the Trust team at Airbnb
built a TensorFlow model
to detect if a profile
picture that you're
trying to upload
directly in the client
contains government-issued IDs.
They use this in the
browser, using TensorFlow.js,
as well as on their mobile
devices with TFLite.
On Node.js, a good example of
this being used in the industry
is Clinic Doctor and Clinic.js.
This is a Node.js
performance analysis tool.
And they use our
Node.js bindings
to filter out GC
spikes on [? node ?]
processes that are running
to give a true, accurate CPU
performance benchmark.
And on the desktop, our
team here at Google,
with Magenta and their
music generation models,
have built a series of desktop
plugins for the Ableton Studio.
So these apps are a
little mini-applications
that are full desktop
applications that
use the Magenta models and
accelerate them all into GPU
and desktop applications.
And we have a demo at our booth,
as well, for how this works.
Again, the really cool part
is all JavaScript and GPU
acceleration on the desktop,
with no CUDA drivers
all through our webGL bindings.
And mobile is another
interesting space.
WeChat, for example, is one
of the most popular apps
in the world.
They have over one
billion total users
and have a
sub-application platform
called the mini-programs.
The mini-programs are
great because it's
a no need to install app
in advance, use on-demand.
And it has over one million
apps and 1.5 million developers.
The mini-program itself
is built using JavaScript.
And it makes it really
easy for developers
to create and deploy and share
these on the WeChat platform.
I actually want to show a
demo of one of our TFJS models
running on WeChat.
So I have just a
regular iOS device here,
and I'm going to open WeChat.
Someone shared with
me this TFJS example.
And I can load up
the application,
and it's running
our PoseNet model.
And if I aim at it
Yannick here, I can do--
yeah, there we go.
So this is just purely
done in JavaScript.
And it's running our
off-the-shelf MobileNet model.
And we're doing about
30 frames a second.
And this is all done with the
WeChat JavaScript platform.
YANNICK ASSOGBA: Thank you.
So all this work over the past
year and the fantastic projects
created by the community
makes us very excited
to announce
TensorFlow.js 1.0 today.
It's available now.
And we're super excited to
see what that community builds
with it and hope that
the API stability will
make this even easier for
developers, going forward.
And really with
this release, we're
focusing on two main things--
providing a stable API that you
can build applications
on and make
managing your upgrades
easier, and also bringing
marked improvements in
performance, particularly
on mobile devices.
And we'll look at that
in a bit more detail.
So to look at it a bit closer--
since we announced TensorFlow.js
last year at the Dev Summit,
we've been steadily working
on performance improvements
across a number of platforms.
And today, we see increases
of about 1.4x to 9x in some
extreme cases.
So this chart shows
inference performance
with a batch size of 1
on MobileNet in Chrome.
So MobileNet is a
mobile-friendly image
classification model.
And we see inference times
going from about 15 milliseconds
on a modern laptop
with discrete graphics
to about 150 milliseconds
on the Pixel 2.
And over the past
year, we've been
able to do quite a bit of
work to improve performance
on iOS devices as well.
So really excited
for you to try this.
So what's next for us?
Well, we want to enable
you to execute saved models
on our Node.js backend without
going through the conversion
process.
And this will open
up many more models
to be able to serve
using the Node.js stack.
We want to provide more
off-the-shelf models,
like we talked about
earlier, to make it easier
to build ML-powered JavaScript
apps without getting
into the nitty-gritty of
machine learning models.
We're always keeping an eye on
browser acceleration proposals,
like SIMD and WASM, as
well as emerging proposals,
like WebGPU and WebML.
So the browser's only going
to get faster, and so will we.
And finally, we
also want to work
on expanding the platforms on
which TensorFlow.js can run.
So for example, we saw
examples of Electron
and things like WeChat.
They're also working
on platforms,
like the Raspberry Pi and
other hybrid mobile platforms
that run JavaScript.
So thanks.
And for more information about
the things we talked about,
you can visit any
one of these links.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]